oh go and rest my name is Brianna back
welcome back to have a new trick man I
feel like I need a welcome back
ah you saw oh you missed man anyway
we're gonna good here I had a great time
in LA I missed making videos but College
shut Barrows I'll tell you doing here
well yeah well what do flying potatoes
how's he doing
tell me talk to me oh he's writing
cheese oh you got a ratchet dude that's
at all well that's some awesome
acrobatics holy [ __ ]
I will never tell you how to do it but
look I'm gorgeous wow that is pretty
impressive
is your sister what trees whoa Oh what
the [ __ ] potatoes come on god damn it
all right
pretty cool fire it's actually well oh
no oh no no no no no no did it run for
[ __ ] sake all right here we go whoa
what the [ __ ] I thought it would be I
goddamn it you have to carry on I suck
at this think about it when you don't
play amnesia for less care see you later
bye did you guys scout pretty shut up
where did when did you get French what
does that guy doing
well no Nadia no
[ __ ] sack for the trace things I
forget we are together I have to jump
down here let it go
Annie got alright I guess I just keep
routed keep rolling rolling rolling
rolling what I decide yet if I gotta
fire my dad
Jennifer you can't block the way for me
does it all right is it where did you
take it
where did why does it talk what what
it's me bro find out in Chapter two
tricky minds
alright tricky made it cool cool cos I'm
sorry I guess this means I gotta started
a new one
which one should I play alright I guess
I can do it right away
I have so many I don't know oh I
downloaded one wait one second all right
we're back can't remember the continue
comes out of it one night away I'm
starting to think I'm Dyslexic but you
can time whatever it's not it's not I
can talk now either you can read the
text I can't read it but I'm sure it's
something really interesting
probably about something really
interesting
all right if you remember I played the
first can't remember yeah that was awful
I'm sorry but here well now apparently I
drank horse piss god dammit right all
this drink horse piss you thought you
can kill me I'm alive in my monsters too
and we killed everyone no late because
why would they do that you drank the
inside oh good
I thought it was hard speed I guess so
now you're going to lose it
oh now remember now again give up and
come out lady hunt again beautiful name
and that's Ben don't tell me you're
glued thank you Jesus Christ been away
for so long pity
god dammit six days in LA you don't even
have a tan the [ __ ] is up with that
I know whoa nice stand bro
you know what I don't trust you
whoa anything going on here my dad
happened here
I didn't that baby why do you keep I
didn't say anything whoa whoa all right
we good I think we're good
what do you think I think we're good
whoa whoa what is this
oh that gotta hurt you lazy naked it's
mr. Bonin I have to get out why is that
I have to go not helping him or anything
yeah whatever all right guess we can
make it a little cozier I mean it is
pretty hot damn
hey Lana I feel like there's something
behind this no god damn it
why do I owe this story of course Oh
give me that
what are you doing silly silly something
huh maybe it's low why does everything
want a key I don't get that
oh that's cozy hmm give me that good
shut up you're not a cockroach well I
like I like your house actually it's
kind of cozy oh there's nothing I know
you can't forgive me because of what I
have done but the monsters are in your
house and they imprison me too I'm in
the storage room but I locked the doors
why Oh crowbar and somebody open it the
monster took the front door key
all right so archives and storage we
need to find stuff why am i walking
sister hey
finger painting well what the [ __ ] why
can't it's probably here all right mr.
Bowden save you there we go
Oh Barris naked people bunnies hey oh
[ __ ] me I got you [ __ ] you baby what
that's gonna get [ __ ] by a bunny Oh
piggy oh you got me this
I like that bTW I like that a lot Oh
feels good just sex game I know you do
and oh thank you
I can't damn it Oh what the [ __ ]
mr. Bonin yeah yeah a book ha
don't do it piggy Danton wait Oh No hey
like hey then where we going like I
don't know party you must be really good
at pop I don't do anything like is it
raining blood I'm pretty down leg like
god damn it what the hell leg what the
hell I thought you were cool
okay whatever listen I don't think you
can get to me I have a guy
I got the key oh my god baby Shambo I
don't want a shovel right now Bob [ __ ]
man thought I could get away
[ __ ] ah I'm so so bad
it's I know
kids in the back yeah
all right so what's goin down down here
huh that's Dino yeah I know you that's
right I don't know what I'm talkin about
Oh like it - like it - like it - oh I
thought for sure it was good there we go
I give me some some that good it's kind
of creepy and bad your left a note for
me let's [ __ ] off
Lud Beckett what are you the fence is
standing and I will barricade my house
now if you see mr. Rieger you should
ignore him because he's gone crazy going
crazy the last time I saw him he was
climbing in house haha he's going crazy
and [ __ ] it's climbing housing [ __ ]
anyway I lost my [ __ ] Brenda sorry I
have to put a secret secret level to
open the wall well where the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you barrels [ __ ] stop
this nuts
Oh what are you doing yeah [ __ ] man Oh
Oh I [ __ ] you up barrel now [ __ ] you are
CC you grandma
don't touch my grandma pin I don't cap
[ __ ] your grandma that's right whoa
what's going on here till dizzy no my
guess
since it's all in rusty maybe I can
destroy it
[ __ ] I feel drunk holy [ __ ] where is it
barrels give me drugs or something
well I can probably Jennifer all right
good
you're hopeless set aah but I thought I
could help you I don't care just break
the lock you'd suck Jennifer I'm pissed
now
oh that's right that's right well I come
aah oh you [ __ ] bat don't you dare
all in my face ohh ha ha ha
people ask me why are you why do you
hate barrels obvious [ __ ] barrels
make me drunk and [ __ ] and what the hell
can touch him come on Hanah yes yes this
guy's your fix kind of I don't care I
need you right now the monsters are real
lady hanket I love that name came to our
village and they kill everyone I don't
know when they will find me here but if
someone read this they should have take
my hammering because you had to destroy
the fence all right cool who the [ __ ]
did you come from no no no it's my gasps
[ __ ] what the hell do I do
but the hell do I know all right you
will Adam please please we can be
friends
aah [ __ ] [ __ ] broker on the sniffer
of
I don't like it I don't like this I
don't like this I don't like that uh
[ __ ] ah you have to carry on my wayward
son there'll be peace when you lay to
[ __ ] barrels
don't you cry where are the health funds
he said son Sydney there's a fans here
stardom pretty big actually it's gotta
be a weak point it's up for that tree
whoa whoa what the Hat now what the hell
of it what is trees man [ __ ] trees
that is pretty awful huh all right at
least I'm safe for monsters here that's
pretty sweet
thank you kind of kid can use my ladder
Jana what up
I guess I wasn't safe after all you have
to carry on I think I'll do that but in
the next episode
it's good to be back Russ like here did
you feel the same way about me and I'll
keep making a video that's awesome dad
Hey awesome breath that's pretty much it
that awkward ending all right
DeVoe coming home having some boy hi
Oh Cydia happy heart chakras getting it
oh yeah house I mean I was upset